[Music]
time now for our morning rounds this
week we focus on one topic epileptic
seizures according to the Epilepsy
Foundation around 48 of every 100,000
people will develop epilepsy the
condition tends to be more common among
young children and older people and the
seizures can be debilitating but there
is new hope thanks to advancements in
science and technology we're joined by
CBS News chief medical correspondent dr.
Jon LaPook who took a closer look at one
of these developments good morning good
morning anti-seizure medication alone
doesn't work well enough in about one of
three people with epilepsy and for the
past two years
I followed the journey of an
extraordinary family who turned to a
novel treatment eleven-year-old Isabella
Renaldo is a medical pioneer at 18
months she had her first epileptic
seizure at its worst there were five or
six a day she's had them so severe where
they literally knock her off her feet
mom Regina it's heartbreaking it's sad
you know you don't want to see your
child confused and and frightened
medications were failing to control the
epilepsy when two years ago Isabella
became the youngest person implanted
with a kind of defibrillator for the
brain called a neuro pace it was no
precedent for this in somebody her age
what was that like for you that was
scary and and we said alright we know
we're not gonna rush into it and then we
had a really bad day and we were back in
the ER and we said we gotta do this I
can see the seizures building up
building up building up building up dr.
Steven Wolfe specializes in pediatric
epilepsy at Mount Sinai Medical Center
and we found that we were able to stop
her seizures by stimulating it with
electricity so basically we were
fighting fire with fire the device
learns to recognize abnormal brainwave
patterns that left alone would trigger a
seizure but by delivering a small shock
within milliseconds it normalizes brain
activity and prevents the seizure before
surgery doctors make a map of the brain
to pinpoint exactly where seizures occur
it looks like she's about to have a
seizure right now for Isabella
it's where hand and arm movements are
controlled during surgery electrodes are
placed at those sites one month after
surgery the device is switched on you
are now officially stimulating your
brain
we followed Isabella over the next two
years as she was carefully monitored and
the seizures became less frequent we got
an update from the ronaldo's this past
fall
we've been seizure free for six months
and we actually started to wean one of
her medications before she was more
subdued tired now she is more alert
she's more energetic she's more eager to
try new things you can do karate right I
have to learn to let go a little bit
more because I'm just so used to being
all over her waiting for something to
happen and you know sometimes I'll jump
in and like I'm 11 I can do it myself
how was mom feeling moms feeling proud
how's isabella feeling she just turned
12 there sent 12 in March I spoke to her
mom yesterday and you know when I last
spoke to her mom she said you know she's
becoming a little sassy when I spoke to
her yesterday I said if she's still
sassy she said yeah she's still sassy
but you know what she's earned it yes
good we like sass you know I think
people in America might be surprised
just how many people actually suffer
from seizures do you think this really
is a game changer well I think it's one
piece of the puzzle you have about
two-thirds of people whose seizures are
adequately controlled with medication
but then for the other third it can be a
real problem and devastating especially
if you're a kid you're trying to fit in
with your schoolmates and you're trying
to have normal development so for those
other third there there's other things
there's a ketogenic diet there's
something called the vagus nerve
stimulation there's new medications that
are being developed for but for the
people for whom the medications the diet
doesn't work this is a technological
tour de force and you think about it I
was in the operating room you couldn't
tell right I was behind the mask
and I got to tell you that moment went
when the doctor says oh there it is
there it is it's about to happen and
then you can actually see the moment
where the seizure is about to happen and
it's kind of like a defibrillator right
yeah and it just is about to start boom
it zaps it and it stops this is you're
free now she is for six months well what
happened was I spoke to her mom
yesterday they tried to tape her she was
on three meds they tried to tape her one
of them they stopped that one and she
got a few more seizures again so they
had a give her just a little bit of it
but for the first six week for the last
six weeks she's been seizure free and
you know she may need medication for the
rest of her life but if she's controlled
her seizures controlled that would be
amazing for and she's an extraordinary
young doctor Jon LaPook thank you so
much for being with us this morning
great to see you